[Musique]
bonsoir heureux de vous retrouver pour
ce nouveau cette ut le journal voici les
titres
c'est benoît hamon qui représentera le
ps lors de l'élection présidentielle de
vainqueur du second tour de la primaire
de la gauche avec 58 eur 87 % face à
manuel valls
nous reviendrons sur cette soirée les
différentes réactions dans le
département 1,1 milliard d'euros c'est
le montant du budget du conseil
départemental des yvelines
le vote s'est déroulé vendredi sous la
présidence de pierre bédier
et puis culture et un atelier
scientifique à la commanderie d'élan
pour un rendez-vous résolument futuriste
autour de l'exposition textile avec des
vêtements connectés mais nous débutons
ce journal avec la primaire de la gauche
la primaire de la belle alliance
le verdict est tombé et le vainqueur
député des yvelines benoît hamon a réuni
ses sympathisants hier soir à la salle
de la mutualité à paris
parmi eux des yvelinois justement une
soirée festive sous le signe du
rassemblement de la gauche
le reportage de nicolas kérino vite et
nicolas d'andré 18 heures les festivités
se prépare dans la salle de la mutualité
à paris le lieu choisi par benoît hamon
pour la soirée électorale de ce second
tour
des soutiens évinois ont fait le
déplacement téléphone en main ils
obtiennent les premières tendances dans
les yvelines
pour l'instant j'ai pas de résultats
mais à mon avis ce sera triomphal pour
benoît hamon dans une demi heure
c'est vrai que l'organe participation
est aussi très très
vivifiant pour le résultat qui en
sortira
ce soir mais c'est vrai qu'on reste
malgré tout serein et dans la tente
parce que tant que les résultats ne sont
pas proclamer on ne peut évidemment rien
rien annoncer rien dire écoutez je suis
plutôt confiant j'ai un peu fait le tour
ce matin dans les yvelines
le taux de participation dans les
bureaux de vote à gauche ont beaucoup
participé dans un certains quartiers
notamment aux mureaux le taux de
participation a doublé donc c'est plutôt
une bonne nouvelle mais on attend les
résultats
l'impatience est à son comble tous les
sympathisants leur regard rivé sur leur
portable sur le grand écran à 20h45 les
résultats tombent quand il se présente
devant ses sympathisants le député des
yvelines se pose en candidat pour
l'élection présidentielle
dès lundi je proposerai donc à tous les
candidats à cette primaire les aussi à
tous ceux qui se reconnaissent dans la
gauche et l'écologie politique en
particulier yannick jadot et jean luc
mélenchon de nous penser qu'à l'intérêt
des français au delà des 4 un
rassemblement qui pourrait permettre à
la gauche de se qualifier au second tour
une stratégie politique partagée par
l'ensemble des militants
je pense que ce soir le voeu dur est
fait le plus important reste à faire est
le plus important c'est dès demain
la discussion à gauche pour permettre le
rassemblement et gagner cette
présidentielle
nous en avions déjà les prémices lors du
premier tour et le second tour a fait
que confirmer que les gens les électeurs
et les citoyens de gauche avaient un
besoin de renouvellement et avait un
besoin de rassemblement de la gauche 58%
nationalement 89% rattrape
je suis hyper content maintenant tout
reste à faire parce que c'est qu'une
primaire maintenant en route pour la
présidentielle et vers la victoire le 7
mai prochain dans les premiers sondages
donner après la primaire benoît hamon
serait créditée de 15% au premier tour
ils devanceraient jean luc mélenchon de
donner à 10% et nous reviendrons un peu
plus tard sur les réactions dans le
département suite à la victoire de
benoît hamon au deuxième tour de la
primaire de la gauche
un carambolage entre plusieurs véhicules
a fait 60 blessés dont cinq en urgence
absolue ce lundi matin dans les yvelines
conséquence la xiii était coupée entre
la normandie et paris ce matin 1,1
milliard d'euros c'est le budget 2010
est des yvelines bonne nouvelle pour
cette année le département n'augmente à
part ça fixe sa fiscalité
le vote a eu lieu vendredi dernier dans
une atmosphère plutôt tendu le budget
des yvelines dont l'année 2010 est vient
d'être votée par l'assemblée
départementale
il s'élève à 1,1 milliard d'euros pour
un total de dépenses de 970 millions
le département est l'un des plus
économes de france a rappelé son
président pierre bédier qui a également
promis de ne plus toucher à la fiscalité
pour les yvelinois je crois la nouvelle
la plus importante c'est la fiscalité
n'augmentera pas l'an passé le
département a été contraint par ce que
l'état nous avait pris près de 200
millions d'euros l'équivalent de 20 % de
notre budget nous avions été contraints
d'augmenter notre fiscalité cette année
nous avons absorber ce choc maintenir le
même niveau d'investissement qu'en 2016
sans augmenter les impôts
une équation difficile alors que le
département reçoit de moins en moins
d'argent de l'état
certains postes de dépenses ont été
revues à la baisse c'est le cas des
subventions aux crèches qui ont été
supprimés aucune conséquence de toute
façon puisque les familles
toujours la même somme puisque les
tarifs des crèches sont fixés par la caf
donc là il n'y a aucune modification des
tarifs payés par les familles dans les
crèches
un dossier continuent d'entacher les
discussions au niveau départemental
celui du rapprochement avec les hauts de
seine le projet permettrait de réaliser
des économies d'échelle et ce dès 2017
selon ses défenseurs mais certains
souhaitent plus de détails
je pense principalement au transfert de
tout le personnel sur tous les sites de
versailles sur un immeuble qui seraient
loués à guyancourt
c'est aujourd'hui officiel pour le
personnel et ce n'est pas officiel ni
pour les élus ni à l'assemblée ni dans
ce budget enfin s'agissant de l'avenir
le département investira en priorité
dans les projets de mobilité telles que
le tram à 13 est le prolongement du rer
e
[Musique]
samedi dernier un atelier sont
scientifiques a eu lieu à la commanderie
d'elancourt l'événement avait pour but
de sensibiliser le public aux enjeux du
textile connecter un futur connectés
grâce à la fibre textile c'est ce que
propose l'atelier des sciences à
elancourt une innovation avec des files
connectés qui permettent l'amélioration
de ses vêtements en devenant tactile
l'atelier consiste à coudre du fil
conducteur au bout de doigts de gand qui
permet en fait par la suite utiliser ses
gants avec un téléphone portable donc
avec l'écran d'un smartphone ce qui
n'est pas possible normalement quand il
sait de la laine qui est
constitué de l'extrémité des gants un
mélange entre une pratique ancestrale et
la nouvelle technologie qui réconcilie
les petits comme les grands avec la
couture j'ai un grand plutôt épais du
coup c'est un peu compliqué à coudre
mais après c'est oui c'est vrai c'est
étonnant juste avec un fils de réussir à
bâle taper sur leur téléphone fixe a
marre c'est une étape une étape qui va
venir dans quelques années qui nous
paraîtra incontournable un peu comme les
téléphones portables mais à voir son sur
son vêtement une lumière qui annonce par
exemple je sais pas moi un problème
sanguin pour l'âme de coeur ou un truc
comme ça ou sur même plus une montre on
ne peut même plus besoin d'une montre on
regardera son pull loose à son pantalon
en or à l'heure voilà et puis c'est bon
quoi avec ces avancées du futur la meute
se retrouvent révolutionner nouveaux
textiles nouvelles créations mais aussi
nouvelles formes les vêtements se
moderniser change d'aspect les textiles
électronique prend une grande place
il ya des recherches qui sont effectués
à la fois par les entreprises par les
fab lab par les centres de recherche
mais aussi par les créateurs des
créations facile à faire et des
nouveautés à retrouver le samedi 4
février à 14h 30 à l'atelier des
sciences à elancourt et samedi dernier
la ville de plaisir à inaugurer wasa des
gâtines qui se trouvent 25 64 rue jules
régner une centaine de personnes étaient
présentes pour l'occasion ainsi que
gérard larcher président du sénat et
coûter le maire de la mer de plaisir
joséphine colson man berger c'est une
salle que je connais depuis plus de 30
ans et je les ai vus dans toutes ses
activités
avec toute cette passion qui avait
l'intérieur par le biais des
associations et puis des écoles et de
tous les plaisirs oies et c'était
important pour nous de la refaire donc
voilà ça y est c'est fait donc on est
ravis puisque on a pu faire exactement
ce qu'on voulait avec la qualité que
nous souhaitions justement pour le
respect des plaisirs wa donc et puis
gérard larcher était là quand même
je trouve que c'est important et puis on
avait pas mal d'élus qui était des
nôtres donc pas la petite un moment fort
et reviendront qu'en politique avec
cette victoire de benoît hamon
et on va découvrir les réactions dans le
département avec moules-frites bridge
bonsoir haussmann réaction et résultats
également dans le département pour
débuter un mot sur cette participation
sur le plan national plus de deux
millions de personnes se sont déplacées
comme pour le premier tour on reste en
dessous des records atteints lors de la
primaire de la droite mais on note
néanmoins une progression entre le
premier et le second tour progression
aussi dans le département des yvelines
de quarante mille votants au premier
tour nous sommes maintenant presque à 48
milles et c'est peu dire que ces
chiffres étaient particulièrement le
scruter après les cafouillages de la
semaine dernière côté résultats à
présent voici dans les yvelines les
scores des deux finalistes
et l'on constate que benoît hamon
totalise 58 54 % des suffrages exprimés
c'est un petit peu moins bien un tout
petit peu moins bien qu'au niveau
national mais cela reste une victoire
très nette
regardez ce chiffre pour la seule
commune de trappes ou benoît hamon
siéger en tant que conseiller municipal
il ya quelques mois encore il dépasse
les 80 9% et on notera que la
participation dans cette ville a
augmenté de 90% entre les deux tours
alors au delà des chiffres ce sont des
réactions cela au delà est déchiffré
bien les différentes réactions on va
commencer par celle de catherine tasca
sénatrice des yvelines elle soutenait à
manuel valls dans cette primaire elle
évoqué pendant l'entre-deux-tours une
catastrophe en cas de victoire de benoît
hamon en raison de propositions
impossible à réaliser voici son point de
vue aujourd'hui lundi le je suis
évidemment déçu évidemment déçu parce
que je porte une grande et finma manuel
valls est au travail qui l'a menée qu'il
aurait pu mener ce qui est en notre part
qui a choisi de faire une primaire
personnellement je n'ai jamais été
favorable à ce mode de sélection de
notre candidat ne peut pas s'agir d'un
ralliement pure et simple à celui qui
est sorti victorieux de cette étrange
primaire et bien il faut du travail il
faut voir sur quoi on peut tendre à
droite à présent quelques réactions
également même si
mettant en pleine tourmente pour le
candidat françois fillon suit avec
attention les résultats de cette
primaire des socialistes vous allez
entendre sophie primas c'est la numéro
deux des républicains dans le
département des yvelines et puis juste
après jean michel fourgous c'est le
maire d'elancourt et les candidats aux
législatives pour les républicains donc
dans la 11e circonscription
circonscription détenue aujourd'hui par
benoît hamon une bonne nouvelle
cependant comme d'habitude tracer un
chemin avec 38 millions depuis plusieurs
années donc l'élection de la gauche est
un épiphénomène au tour voilà autour du
programme que nous étions déroulé de la
campagne que nous soyons ya une fracture
très très important de la gauche en
trois blocs qu'on retrouve là mélenchon
très très à gauche il tellement à gauche
qu'il y en est proche de marine le pen
benoît hamon qui sur une ligne la ligne
j'allais dire dure du parti socialiste
qu'on n'avait pas connu depuis très
longtemps et puis m'a conquis légèrement
que françois hollande en plus jeune et
plus fantastique mitterrand avait réduit
les points gauche et une partie clinique
à mon art et société epson gauche et
parce que les centres en amont de l'est
frappés par une culture et que les
mixtes étoiles on revient tout ce qui
contient de la pas une seule composition
déco dès lors qu'on a pas une seule
marque d'équipé ville
il yal elle que j'ai connu mon parti
socialiste soit de l'espoir est là alors
la primaire terminée on connaît
maintenant avec quasi certitude la liste
des candidats à la présidentielle il
faudra attendre le mois de mars pour
avoir les noms définitifs mais benoît
hamon doit représenter le parti
socialiste la ligne défendue pendant la
campagne va donc être clair on sera à
gauche et de la gauche comment les
autres formations réagissent on écoute
les représentants locaux de ces
différentes formations politiques
c'est une très bonne chose quand on voit
les vides et que benoît hamon a présenté
qui ont obtenu une part importante des
suffrages et qui sont très proches des
notes donc plus de quelques chants
qu'ils ont ouverte évident est la mieux
donc on peut être que satisfait de ce
côté là après entre
ce que benoît hamon propose en tant que
candidat et le programme du parti
socialiste a lui même falloir que
vérifier exactement ce qui va se passer
et après da c était quelque chose
effectivement qui est intéressant il
faut faut rejeter aucune hypothèse pour
l'instant c'est plutôt une bonne
nouvelle de voir que quelqu'un qui
répètent excusé allègrement soutien des
gréements dans notre programme arrive à
abattre manuel valls qui représente la
politique est certes entre alors s'est
offert des personnalités qu'il faut
rassembler la gauche c'est autour d'un
programme et d'un programme qui forment
un tout clair et cohérent
et effectivement la cinquième république
nous obliger à avoir un candidat pour
porter ce programme il faut essayer de
choisir un candidat qui n'incarne pas le
bilan des sortants un candidat qui soit
cohérent pendant pendant des années a
défendu et a travaillé sur la même ligne
benoît hamon a dit
sur beaucoup de points et ce il se
reconnaît dans ce que nous disons bon
contact nous en tout cas nous ne sommes
pas dans une logique de négociations
d'appareil
nous parlons au peuple français vous
proposons un projet et je constate
effectivement que sur beaucoup de points
il nous rejoint et il fait la même le
même diagnostic la même analyse que nous
devons refonder notre système politique
repenser non non non aux clivages et
essayer de réunir
d'un côté les progressistes pour pouvoir
répondre aux conservateurs parce qu'on
se rend compte bien que les
conservateurs sont aussi bien à gauche
qu'à droite aujourd'hui tu es assez
prévisible finalement qu'un candidat
frondeurs comme l'emportent
là on voit que quand même il passa à 15
% dans les sondages dépasse même jean
luc mélenchon contre qui marine le pen
on va se retrouver au 2e tour c'est pas
ça ça peut ça peut véritablement être
être à mon avis un deuxième tour très
intéressant avec peut-être pourquoi
prendre si les la gauche arrive à faire
l'union peut être un deuxième tour
contre des candidats comme mélenchon ou
hamon lequel va égaliser 7 membres s'ils
arrivent à se mettre d'accord il
s'appelait très intéressant oui merci
pour toutes ces infos où ils federici
c'est la fin de ce journal
bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]